مرحب بكم تدك سود
مدني وضاح سليمان فكي علي مهندس ميكانيكي
خريج جامعه السودان
2013 حقيقه انا حابي اشارككم يعني فكره
كانت فريده من نوع او تجربه فريده من
نوعها بالنسبه لي غيرت طريقه غيرت اسلوب
حياتي تماما غيرت مفهومي عن العمل الجماعي
عن الابداع عن التعامل مع السلبيه
الموجوده في المجتمع السوداني
عموما المشروع بتاعنا كان مشروع بتاع
تخرج اسمه الاتش اش او انجين او محرك يعمل
بغازات
الهيدروجين الفكره
كانت حلم بالنسبه لواحده زميلتنا
قبل ما نتكلم عن المشروع حابه انه اقدم
لكم التيم اللي اشتغل على المشروع
دي باشمهندسه نفيسه محمد سعيد هندسه
ميكانيك جامعه
السودان باشمهندس امجد
مصطفى باشمهندسه هبه
عادل موجودين معان الليله امجد وه
هنركز على هبه عادل باعتبارها كانت هي
محور
المشروع الضع سليمان شايفيني قدامكم دي
التيم اللي اشتغل في الفتره من 2011 لحد
2013 بعد كده في تيم تاني ج واصل بعدنا
اللي هم خالد احمد خضر عمر الجيلي ومحمد
الفاتح الفكره بتاع المشروع جت من وين في
2011 كنا موجودين في معمل محركات الاحتراق
الداخلي انا وزميلتي الباشمهندسه هبه فكان
بتتكلم انه هي عايزه تعمل مشروع بتاع تخرج
يعني يضع بصمتها في الجامعه ما عايزه تعمل
مشروع تقليدي تتخرج به والسلام كان هي
بتقول عندها عربيه شغاله بالمويه والحلم
ده براو طوالي وجيت بالعربيه الشغاله
بالمويه وما قاعد اكب بنزين فاقترحت على
ان يعني الفكره دي احنا نطبقها وتبقى تخرج
بالنسبه لينا يعني باعتبارها حتكون اول
مره حصلت في السودان ويعني يمكن تكون من
التجارب القليله في الشرق الاوسط بدات
طرحت عليها
الفكره في
نهايه
2011 التايم لاين دي حورينا اللايف تايم
بتاع المشروع بتاعنا كله خطوه
بخطوه يعني بقينا انه نحنا عايزين نقري عن
احنا كيف ممكن نستخلص الهيدروجين من
المويه الطرق ممكن نستخلص بها الهيدروجين
بتدينا كفاءه بتاع تحليل كهربي عاليه جدا
او كفا بتاع التوليد للهيدروجين عاليه
جدا المشروع كان كبير علينا احنا ان نكون
اثنين بس بدينا نبحث عن الناس ممكن يكون
عندهم اهتمامات بالطاقه البديله ممكن
يكونوا تيم ورك متجانس نقدر نطلع به بعمل
مبدع باعتبار ان المشروع كبير جدا قررنا
انه 2011 كلها تكون عباره عن
دا جمع للبيانات نصل لش ديزاين احنا
المفروض نشتغل
عليه فعلا 2011 كانت عباره عن داتا لحد ما
وصلنا في نهايه 2011 للتصميم النهائي بتاع
الخلايا بتاع التحليل الهيدروجين او فصل
الهيدروجين كهربائيا من
المويه بتتكون الخليه من مت
مت تعمل على فصل الهيدروجين والاكسجين من
المو بعد كده الهيدروجين ده احنا بنستخدمه
كوقود الفكره في بدايتها ان نستخدم
الهيدروجين بس ما نستخدم معه اي اضافات
تانيه في بدايه 2012 احنا كنا انتهينا من
الداتا ج وصلنا لمستوى
الخامس على اساس ان حنبدا الشغل
العملي
طوالي بدينا الشغل العملي بحماس عالي
جدا حاولنا ان نستخدم لوك ماتيريال عشان
نقلل الكوست بتاع المشروع له معظم المواد
اللي احنا حاولنا نتحصل عل اما ما متوفره
في السوق السوداني او متوفره باسعار عاليه
جدا وكوالتي
منخفضه اشتغلنا اول حاجه
بالوم التحليل الكهربي عملنا الخلايا
الاوليه بتاعتنا يعني للاسف هي ادتنا
نتائج كويسه بتاع التحليل لغازات
الهيدروجين لكن كان معدل التاكل بتاع عالي
الصوره الموجوده على
اليمينيوم التاكل بتاع الالومنيوم كان
عالي جدا انا عشان اسوق الحاجه دي بعدين
بعد المشروع بتاعي ينجح انا ما ممكن اسوق
حاجه يعني هي حتخسر اكثر من ما توفرلك
ممكن كل 20 ساعه تشغيليه انا اغير اللقط
بتاع التحليل الكهربي بدينا نبحث انه نحنا
كيف نستعيض عن الاقطاب بتاع التحليل بماده
قليله التاكل الخيار الامثل لحد الان هو
الاستانلستيل او الحديد الغير قابل للصدا
معدل التاكل بتاعه عالي الموصليه الكهربيه
بتاعته ممتازه جدا لكن بدات هنا تواجهنا
مشكلات كل مشكله تتشعب منها اربعه خمس
مشاكل
تانيه يمكن كانت من اكثر المشكلات
المواجهه هي المشاكل الماديه انه ما في
ممول حقيقي للمشروع مشروع مكلف جدا
ا تمويل من الجامعه يعني كاد يكون
منعدم المشاكل الثانيه انه بعد ما احنا
انتهينا من التصميم الاولي للخلايا
والاختبارات
بتاعتها هي كانت مشاكل تقنيه انه نحنا كيف
نحسب الفلوريت بتاعنا بطريقه علميه ومور
اكيوريت نحسب نسب غازات التحليل الطالعه
هو ما طالع هيدروجين اكسجين بس في عندي
سبعه غازات طالعه ثاني غيرهم
ان نحنا نحسب الكميه دي لان هي بتاثر لنا
في بيئه عمل
المحرك المشكله
الثانيه كانت ان احنا نحسب الكرنت بيستهلك
كل خليه بتاع التحليل الكهربي بطرق علميه
يعني المشاكل دي كلها كانت بتواجهنا لانه
للاسف في الجامعات السودانيه يعني ما في
معامل مؤهله بالصوره الكافيه عشان انت
تشتغل على مشروعك من الالف الى الياء ط
هلنا حقيف على كده يعني الحمد لله التيم
ويرك اللي كان
شغال كان يعني تفكيره ايجابي جدا بدينا ان
احنا نفتش حلول للمشاكل دي نتحايل عل بانه
نستخدم طرق تقليديه لكن تديني نتائج بتاع
قرايات مور
اكيوريت لحد ما
وصلنا للاختبارات النهائيه للمحرك عملنا
اختباراتنا في معمل محركات الاحتراق
الداخلي في جامعه سودان بالبيورين جبنا
الخلايا بتاعتنا وصلناها في المحرك
شغلنا الانجن الحمد لله يعني اشتغل بالبي
هيدروجين لكن للاسف لمده خمس ثواني
بس احنا خلاص وصدمنا الوقت يعني مشروع
التخرج المفروض يتسلم في اقل من شهرين اذا
المحرك دي ما اشتغل احنا ممكن نعيد
السنه الفكره كانت انه نحنا نتحايل على
الجامعه ما قدامنا حل تاني حولنا اسم
المشروع بتاعنا من الاتش ا انجين لرين ا
انج بترول اللي هو خليط بين الهيدروجين
والبنزين قررنا انه نحنا نغير مجال البحث
تماما انه ندرس التاثير بتاع اضافات
الهيدروجين على بيئه المحرك على معدل
استهلاك الوقود على البور الطالعه معي من
الانج
رام وضح
لنا الدكشن حصل في استهلاك الوقود لما
ضفنا الهيدروجين الريد لاين هو المين
هيدروجين بترول البلو لاين هو الرول مع
الهيدروجين في سرعات معينه التقليل في
الاستهلاك وصل لحد 28% دي سرعات بدون
الاحمال يعني المكنه بتكون شغاله من غير
ما تكون شايله معه حاجه
تاني
ريشن
استهلاك الوقود مع الاحمال يعني المكنه
تكون شغاله انا بسلط عليها حمل الحمل دي
هو بياخد لي جزء من الباور انا داار اشوف
الاستهلاك بتاع الوقود بتاعي كيف لما اكون
شايل باور من الانجن قل في السرعات
المنخفضه بنسبه تصل لحد
30% المفاجاه
كانت في انبعاثات العادم يعني نحنا ما كنا
اصلا حاطينها في الحسبان الاضافات قللت
قللت انبعاثات غازات العادم بالنسبه لاول
اكسيد الكربون غاز سام بنسب تصل لحد 90%
في السرعات المنخفضه يعني النسبه دي حتى
في الوقود الحيوي ما قاعد تحصل بالنسبه
لاكاسيد الكبريت قلت لحد 55% في السرعات
المنخفضه قدمنا المشروع بتاعنا عشان
يتناقش في نهايه في بدايات
2013 ناقشنا المشروع كنا متخوفين انه
الناس يجف لنا في حته انه
مكشر مع الانجن لكن الحمد
لله ناقشنا وتخرجنا واخدنا امتياز في
المشروع طيب بعد اخدنا امتياز
هل احنا حقف على كده يعني حقيقه رغم
الفرحه بتاع الامتياز
والتخرج لكن كنا محبطين تماما انه المشروع
بتاعنا لسه ما راى
النور خذنا فتره بتاع اربع شهور الناس
خلاص بدات تنسى المشروع لحد ما جيم بعدنا
خالد وعمر الجيلي ومحمد الفاتح اقترح
علينا ان عايزين يواصل في
المشروع طرحوا الفكره على المشرف بتاعنا
وافق عليها لكن بشرط ان ما تكون في
اختبارات معمليه تطبق في عربيه تكون شغاله
على ارض الواقع عشان الناس تعرف عن
المشروع تكون باعتبار ترويج للفكره
بتاعتنا
الشباب اشتغلوا عملوا انستليشن للخلايا
بتاع التحليل الكهربي في عربا بوكس تويوتا
موديل
84 واجهتهم مشاكل اكثر من المشاكل ال
واجهتنا باعتبار الخلايا دي حتكون متحركه
في عربيه لافه بتتعرض
ل الاجواء المحيطه ليها في فايبريشن عالي
الحمد لله قدروا انهم يتغلبوا على المشاكل
دي وعملوا اختبارات الطريق
اختبارات الطريق يعني كانت نسبتها قريبه
للنتائج المعمليه اللي احنا وصلنا لها
الحمد
لله بعد كده نحنا لحد هسه العربيه لافه في
الشوارع ما في زول دار يتبنى المشروع ما
في زول عرف حاجه عن المشروع اصلا اي زول
بيشوف المشروع بيقوللك يا اخي انت قالين
روحكم عملت حاجه حاجه دي لو بتشتغل كان
عمل الخواجات طرحنا الفكره على عماده
البحث العلمي في الجامعه انه يتعمل
بريزنتيشن البرزنتيشن دي ندع الجهات اللي
بتهتم بمجال الطاقات البديله الوزارات
ممكن تتبنى المشروع دي الوسائل
الاعلام فعلا اتعمل البرزنتيشن ادعت كل
الجهات دي نسبه الحضور للاسف كانت ضعيفه
جدا يعني من وسائل الاعلام يمكن جو ثلاثه
ولا اربعه صحف معام قناه
فضائيه بعد البرزنتيشن اتعمل قررنا انه
نطلع مع الصحف والقنوات المصوره دي نعمل
لهم جوله في مدينه
الخرطوم العربه بتاع الاتش اتش او فعلا
اعملت
الجوله بعدها بثلاثه يوم بس يعني عملنا
راو اعلامي كبير جدا يعني
غال صحف كثيره بدات تكتب عن الموضوع بدات
تتناول الموضوع في وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي بعد كده كان في قنوات فضائيه
كثيره جت بدات تصور معانا كان من ضمن من
القنوات المحليه قناه الشروق في قنوات
عالميه سكاي نيوز الحره دبي المنار في
كربلاء
العربيه
يعني حقيقه انا ما كنت قادر يعني في
اللحظه اللي بدينا صورنا فيها مع سكاي
نيوز انه انا ما متوقع اصلا في يوم من
الايام المشروع هياخذ الرواج الاعلامي دي
او انه فكرتنا حتصل للمستوى
دييه كنت متوقع انه حيكون يعني في جهه
سودانيه اصيله من الشركات الوطنيه حتقدم
لنا فكره انها تتبنى المشروع لكن كلها
كانت عباره عن زي ما
يقولوا اتصالات خجوله جدا يعني تتصل معانا
وزاره ان احنا عايزين نعرف عن المشروع
بتاعكم يعرف عن المشروع سمينار سمنار
الموضوع ينتهي على
كده لكن لحد هسه نحنا حققنا الحلم بنسبه
30% قدر النسبه اللي خفضنا في استهلاك
الوقود في يوم من الايام ان شاء الله
هتشوف العربات بتاعه الهيدروجين دي لافه
في الشوارع السودانيه كمخترع سوداني ميد
ان
سودان
لكن الحاجه دي ما حتكون لليله ولا بكره
ولا بعده ولا يمكن حتى السنه الجايه ان
محتاجه زمن طويل في البحث محتاجه لمصادر
بتاع التمويل محتاجه لمراكز بتاعه ابحاث
وجامعات تتكاتف كلها مع بعض عشان الحاجه
دي ترى النور بصوره علميه بصوره صناعيه
الناس تقدر تسوقها وتروج لكن كافراد ممكن
تاخذ مننا ع سنوات في النهايه حاب اشكر
تدكس مدني حققلي حلم انا كنت بحلم ب من
2011 اول تدكس في الخرطوم انا حضرته كنت
بحدث نفسي هل ممكن انا حكون في يوم من
الايام تدكس سبيكر شكرا تكسد مدني انكحت
الفرصه
دي سعيد ان اكون في مدينه ودمدني لاول مره
مرحب